all right there we are good day good
evening good night wherever you are in
the world
um my name is andreas i work for a
consultancy in
toronto called beck today we're going to
talk about
a product called openfast and server
less
so as most of you hopefully
know by now the serverless hype and the
serverless pattern
it's actually still made of servers
it's just a technology pattern that the
cloud providers has given us that
abstracts away
as much as possible of the need to run
servers or even think about servers
there are still some servers there but
you don't have to
think about them yourself when we talk
about
serverless what we usually mean is
function as a service so i'm gonna
probably mix up those two words but if i
say serverless
i mean functionality service or if i say
functional service i of course mean
serverless if you take a look at
what the cloud providers has been
offering us
over the last couple of years we can see
a clear pattern here is that they have
taken over more and more of
the maintenance of the actual servers
and the technologies needed to
host your code one of the first things
that arrived was infrastructure as a
service which took away the need for you
to host your own data centers
the cloud providers will offer you some
virtualization platform you will run
your oss on top of them
either if it was linux or windows but
then you still had to
think about the runtimes that your
application needed
and then of course you had to write
through applications
and an application is as we know built
up or functions
then platform as a service came around
and now even the os and the runtime was
extra
abstracted away from you you didn't have
to think that much about it
containers and kubernetes is a good
example of this you pick a language and
you pick
some sort of web framework or runtime
and then you could wrap it up in a
container and
the cloud providers would run this for
you and scale it for you
now the next level up the abstraction
stack is them to take away all that and
just function
and just focus on the functions
themselves
which means that the part you deliver
them
is no longer a dll or a container and
time or
a virtual machine is your actual codes
your actual functions
your classes so this is what we're going
to take a look at today
the cloud providers have each their own
option for function as a service
uh google has google cloud functions um
microsoft has azure functions and amazon
has lambda functions
or yeah amazon aws lambda so with
function as
a service and those patterns in our
toolbox
what can we actually do how do we
leverage this in our applications
a very common pattern that you see is
that
we break up our systems into
isolated parts that can be
scaled and deployed individually of each
other
so when when the microservices
hit some years ago what it was all about
was hacking up our monolithic systems
into smaller parts that could be
deployed
individually of each other or hopefully
individually of
each other and then scaled up and down
as you needed it
if one part of your system uh had a lot
of loads
if you were back in a monolithic base
then you would have to scale the entire
system even if parts of it wasn't used
when microservices came around you could
hack out
those pieces and scale them and deploy
them individually
now functions serverless and functional
services take that even further
and breaks out your actual lines of code
or functions into parts
that can be deployed and run individual
of
each other another great thing about
functions is that
when a function is not used when a code
is not running
there is no process idling they will
trigger
as they are needed
so the usual way you write
architecture around functions is that
they are event driven
it means that they are triggered by some
event happening
it might be a message uh occurring on a
queue
it might be a database rule that's
changed it might
be triggered by a http function from
another part of the system
or it might be a scheduled trigger
schedule function
an example of this might be if you have
some iot devices
like some sensors which are which are
posting up
some readings might be temperature
sensors for instance
the these sensor buildings can be
can be sent to a function which has only
one
job and it's to parse parse the values
and put them in something like a time
series database
that you can use some sort of dashboard
over
to have a look at because if you think
about this use case
it makes no sense to have like a
complete server stack
just to take some simple readings
convert the data and put them in the
data store
a more advanced example from
real life is that a company i used to
call the workforce called bluei robotics
who is
the maker of underwater drones that some
of you might have heard about
in when we were diving with our drones
we generated a lot of metrics and
and log files to be able to analyze
these log files to look for errors or
just get a status status report of how
the drone we're doing we were uploading
the actual log files
to azure blob storage
and when a log file a raw log file hit
the blob storage
that would trigger a function an azure
function
that would convert the log file data
and put it in a relational database and
when the data was put in database that
was trigger that will trigger another
function
that would go through the content and
look for errors like if you have a
humidity spike
that might indicate a leak in the drone
for instance
and if any of those readings were off it
was uh
that function would send a message a
message to slack to notify us right away
if anything was wrong
the best part about this design is that
for bluei robotics who were making
underwater drones having to
think about keeping servers up for these
particular things
uh is a no go we were making drones
not maintaining servers so in that way
using a function of service and the
serverless pattern
made total sense since serverless
functions also scale
automatically this system would only
cost
what we were actually using in runtimes
so it was quite little
now serverless from a developer
happiness standpoint
is also quite nice let's say you
want to write some simple code that only
takes in one data format and transformed
it to another data format
uh like yeah i like the example with
some log files that you wanted to
put in a database in
that in the old traditional way you will
have to choose some sort of runtime
or language then you would have to
choose a web framework
and then you could get to actually
coding
and writing the functions that took the
input data and transformed it and put it
there where you wanted
version as a service you don't have to
do that you can just
go and write the code and deliver it
to the platform that would run it
so some tips for writing serverless
functions is that they should be
short-lived
they should be single purpose they
should have no state
and they should be auto scaling the
example
on the right on the left side there is
from a typical python
handler i would take some requests and
then just return hello world
and this is how simple a function can be
now a lot of a lot of projects have had
huge success
with the serverless pattern and saved a
lot of money if you don't need to
maintain a server or think about
runtimes that's really great and
since you only pay for the actual
execution time of functions
uh you can cap off lots of money a bit
but you might be thinking yeah this
serverless
thing sounds quite cool but i can't use
it
for some reason but you kind of want you
kind of want to try it
maybe you're doing iot devices
which are operating individually not
talking to the internet per se
or maybe you're out in the fields doing
tech for agriculture which has
bad internet connectivity
or maybe your company or your project
isn't using cloud technologies at all i
know there are a lot
of companies who still use their data
centers that they have in their
basements
this is very common uh but you don't
heard that hear that much about it
because all the hype is about cloud
computing right
so all the guys with vmware farms in
their basements aren't talking that much
about it
and that kind of makes the
kind of makes it hard to try out or use
serverless technologies in your project
but thankfully there is this cool
project called
open file open first
is a serverless platform that you can
install wherever you want which will run
on container technology
hence the little logo with the tail of
the whale and the crates there
was created by a guy named alex ellis at
dockercon in 2017 and has gotten a lot
of traction since then
the project is completely open source
and it contains
a lot of repositories this is the main
one with the uh
with the functional service runtime
as you can see as of last week it had 7
000 stars on youtube
and a lot of contributors so it's a very
alive and good project
if you look at it from 1000 degree
degrees height the main components
of openfast is an api gateway
and a function watchdog the api gateway
is the component that provides the roots
routes to all your functions
this is also what you go through if you
want to create functions or invoke
functions
now the function watchdog is a little
http server written ago
that you integrate inside docker
containers
to handle the communication
to your to your your functions
in a nutshell what the watchdog will do
is that it will take
http requests and it will convert them
into the regular standard in and
standard out
signals that your code can
can convene and of course
since all this uses container technology
and orchestrators
um you can run it
wherever you want with whatever
orchestrator you want
so if you're on a laptop for instance
you can use docker swarm
if you are using virtual servers and
kubernetes
you can you can use that or if you're
doing iot
or edge computing you can use this much
simpler
k3s which is a very downscaled version
of kubernetes
openvol will work just perfectly on all
these platforms
so the way it works is that you can
either use
the ui cli or just rest calls
to talk to the open files gateway the
gateway will then
talk to the false provider and this can
be
a provider for swarm for instance or
kubernetes or
or k2s and the provider is then
responsible for spawning containers
and talking to the functions that are
running in containers
the containers are then of course drawn
from some sort of container industry
like the docker hub
another cool thing about it is that the
gateway
uh also all the pro when you deploy the
product it also comes with a prometheus
installation
and the gateway delivers prometheus
metrics
it also uses the alert manager which is
a part of the prometheus project to
to provide auto scaling capabilities so
based on the traffic
to your functions it will spawn new
instances or containers running your
functions so you can always have this
auto scaling possibility
and as of scaffolding which is what
most developers are interested in we
just want to write code straight away
the false cli is where you go to create
new functions
so what you see here is the command
to run to create a new function based on
python
so this command here um
is where you pick your language in this
instance button three
and you call it python3 function and
then it will
download the docker images needed for
running the code
and it will give you a main.pi file and
what you see there is just a regular
handler which takes in a request and
that's it you can just start writing
your code
so let's see
actually how easy it is to save you from
watching me plunk along on the keyboard
i've
i have some foil wear for you with some
completed code
so we're going to deploy a bike share
function
now a lot of cities has bike sharing
services
which are bikes you can just download an
app for and and then rent and take
wherever you want
what's cool about this these bike
sharing systems is that they in most of
them implement an open standard
for bike sharing so you can actually
write your own custom software that
talks to them so up on github there is a
csv file that contains a list of all
these certified block sharing providers
around the world which
contain api endpoints
so what we are going to do is write a
function
a simple function that just takes that
csv file
reads it and converts it to json so you
can call it from other functions
and then for instance see how many uh
how many
available bikes there are on your
nearest lecturing station
so to get started
i want to i'm a c-sharp developer so i
would like to write my function
in c-sharp so to do that i pull down a
template
for it so i go to i use the first cli
to go to the open files store and pull
down
um an image called ctrl orchestral
and this will give me a template based
on the dotnet castrol
http server but i don't have to think
about that
i'm just running this command as you can
see it will pull down that template for
me so i can use it
the next thing we do is say file cli new
and then select the c sharp language
we're gonna call our project
bike share providers and i'm gonna
prefix
it with admos which is my docker hub
username
because the result of this project will
be a docker container that you can run
so i would like yeah i would like to
prefix it with my username so i can just
push it to dockrobs when when we're done
so as you can see with the output
the function will create a folder called
bikeshareproviders and they
create something called a stack file
which is a yaml
yaml file now if we take a look at this
the stack file which is in this case
called bug share providers
since it doesn't have our project it's
just a configuration
file which you can configure to say
where is my open files gateway
and which functions is a part of this
solution
now in this case we just have one and
you can see the language is c-sharp
the handler which is the folder
containing the serverless functions
is called blockchain provider and the
image will be called bikeshare providers
with the latest tag if you take a quick
look inside the folder which we
just created you can see there are just
two files there and for c-sharp
developers this will look quite familiar
we have
a function handler cs and the function
have their cs project file
and this is all um your code you could
you put your code in the cs file and you
put your uh
the dependencies you need if you need a
name you get packages or something like
that in the cs split file
so if we take a look at
the cs file this is all the code
that is needed to pull down the csv file
containing all the bug share systems
that are available
so as you see from a developer's
standpoint if you just want to
just want to convert something and print
it out that as
json this is actually all the code you
need
so there's no need to like choose a
framework
or or run the server or anything to just
to be able to do this
although all the scaffolding is done for
you
as you can see all the calls are fixed
in one slide so that's quite nice
with that done we run
cli and run the up commands and pass it
the stack file that we just looked at
what will happen now is three things
first
we will build the image again
since open files uses docker containers
it will take the the
net files and it will build it in in the
predefined image
and then it will push that image to the
group so it's available
and then it will deploy it and when it's
deployed
it will print out the url to your now
you're now running function that url is
is running on the on the gateway
so if you now take a quick
request to that url you will see that we
will get some json back
and this is just one of the responses is
the address for
the oslo city bike system with the
api url at the bottom
you can either call it via curl or you
can use the cli itself to just invoke
methods the result will be the same or
you can even use the pre
pre-built ui which open files provides
you
where you also can see some other
functions which you can invoke you
also get some basic statistics about how
many replications are the running of
this
uh how many times have they been invoked
and so on
so with that function done
the next thing you might want to do is
create
create something that reads one of these
api endpoints endpoints for a bike
provider
and maybe print out how many available
bikes there are
and maybe you want to use use javascript
for this
you want to use node that's no problem
you can just scaffold up a new function
and select node
as your language and you can append that
to the
stack file that we just looked at that
would be
an exercise for the curious we don't
have time for to do that now
but to summarize the openfast platform
uh it's an open server platform on your
terms
because it's open source and it runs on
container technology you can run it
and everywhere so that can be in your
vmware cluster in the basement
or it can be up in azure with the azure
container services or it could be
in google cloud or with amazon it
doesn't have to
doesn't matter and that also avoids
cloud login
you don't have to sell your soul to one
of the cloud providers
you can easily move it around which
gives you uh
flexibility another cool thing about
open files is
because of the function watchdog
which i mentioned um the code you're
running or the container you're running
doesn't actually has to be have to be a
function it can also be an existing
microservice
so let's say you have some functions
that you want to write run side by side
with an existing microservices you can
just implement that watchdog in your
existing docker file
and you can run them side by side you
can let open first
manage the deployment so then you can
convert them to
other services if you want to uh in your
own time
it just also makes deployment to
kubernetes
a bit easier than it is today because
one of the big drawbacks with kubernetes
is that it can be really hard to
to manage and handle so open files is a
quite a good
abstraction on top of that
so that was what i had i hope this was
cool
so for all you serverless guys out there
you should
take a look at open files it's a quite
cool project